[Music]
we both came here as a kid oh so is that
your same actually yeah actually the
classrooms the classroom I started in is
right over there because I know this is
sort of a 360 thing so where those two
ladies are standing is right where I
started with Vincent Farrow who was my
first teacher when I was age 10 me in
the previous facility there was a
classroom right there that's right and
because this is still the foundation of
the old Hayden this was the basis was
the basement and the library was over
there okay where those young ladies are
right yeah I thought I'd died and went
to heaven it was an entire library and
just oh
my gosh it was like
can this be real you know pinch me and
so yeah yeah it's a great place to to be
birthed and our friend sandy sandy Kidd
was the librarian and astronomy
librarian that's right
and she worked with Isaac Asimov oh my
god they were good friends Wow I wrote
you know half a thousand books and many
of them were researched here at this
facility right now that I did not know
yeah and where was your first experience
in here relative to where we are the
optical shop was over there
also two classes in the basement okay I
took one on modern astrophysics and
another one on the frontier of
astrophysics right with Mark Chartrand
DJ orbit calculation no I didn't do what
I tried to ya orbit so it's a hard thing
he was the director all right all right
there's a whole other place where people
made telescopes it was like geek central
before we wore it before there was a big
thing this was oh my gosh the optical
shop grind lenses and and mirrors and
you would build your own telescope and
they all looked homespun but they worked
and every little bit of it also the
bronze
Copernicus bust which is up on your
floor the floor I remember when that was
and so the artist is working on right
yeah there's an exhibit of great minds
of in the history of astrophysics